so it's exciting to be here this is
actually both the first computer science
colloquium I've ever spoken at and the
first one I've ever attended my
background is actually not in computer
science II I know that Mohawk and the
tattoos give it away but I'm a
credentialed actuary but at any rate
I've been working my excel for the last
year and I want to tell you guys about
what we do at Mac seller and as andy
pointed out what the paradigm is in
computing that we're trying to introduce
and essentially trying to overthrow so
I'll start off by answering that
question of you know what is it that
makes processors inefficient or what
makes computers as we know them
inefficient because almost all computers
that we know are based on processors of
some form CPUs GPUs micro processors
that sort of thing so the way I explain
this at a cocktail party when I'm trying
to give somebody who doesn't have a
background you know the five minute
answer is imagine the city of Chicago
one day passes a really bad ordinance
and they say that all of the
white-collar office work all the lawyers
and dentists and doctors and all the
people who work indoors in Chicago all
have to get their work done in the
Willis Tower in one central location
it's very much like the way we build
processors now we have a little tiny bit
of silicon that's dedicated to compute
and everything has to go through there
but we have this problem that Chicago
still has the same number of
white-collar workers right there's still
all these people living all the way out
in the suburbs and in order for them to
get any work done they have to get all
the way to the Willis Tower and back
so being engineering creatures and human
beings we figure this out we say okay
well what we're gonna do is we're gonna
bring all the lawyers in for 10 minutes
they're gonna get all their wool your
ring done right and then they're gonna
have to go and the accountants are gonna
have to come in for 10 minutes and then
what do we have we have a traffic
problem right so now we need to start
building triple decker highways and
thinking of all these different ways of
getting all of those people to and from
the center without colliding with each
other right and at some point some
enterprising developer thing so well I
know how to solve that problem I'll put
in some temporary corporate housing
that's really close to the Willis Tower
and people will sort of swap into it if
they know they're gonna need to be at
work the next day they can stay in one
of these high priced apartments and get
there more quickly and that's basically
right so and then in my metaphor is like
the l1 and l2 cache that sort of thing
if I go and expand this city I don't
really get any
work done right if I go add more houses
to the edge of it it doesn't really get
more done because it all has to go
through that central point and the only
real idea we have for getting more work
out of this kind of a system at this
point in computing is just a copy and
paste right so we put multiple ALUs
multiple cores on a chip and by doing
that sometimes we make them smaller and
weaker like we do in the GPU but the
basic idea is we just can't squeeze any
more power out of one processor so we
start adding coarse so what's happening
now in computer science is that Moore's
Law is still with us we're still packing
transistors on a chip exponentially
we're still doing what's failing now is
frequency scaling right those individual
cores that we're building are no longer
getting that much more powerful with
each generation the way they used to so
instead the only way we can get more
performance is by putting more of them
on a chip and the problem with that is
that performance doesn't come free right
it used to be that if you wrote code and
a processor came out that had doubled
the clock frequency of the last
processor you could compile that same
code for that processor and run twice as
fast we don't get that kind of free
performance anymore now you have to
expose that parallelism in your code now
the reason we do all of this is in
service to one of the oldest ideas in
computing right the control flow model
and in the control flow model which is
by the way every kind of programming
pretty much I'm sure all of you have
ever done have you ever done Python or C
E or it doesn't matter whatever language
you worked and you were doing the
control flow paradigm and and in the
control flow paradigm we treat data like
it's static it lives out in the suburbs
it has a picket fence and an address and
when I want to go get it I go get it I
pick it up I do work with it and I put
it back where I found it we treat
instructions like a kind of data right
so instructions are just a sequence of
data that we go through in time to
actually do our computing with all that
computing and time and Excel or
is that the actual silicon on the chip
there's a lot of stuff that has nothing
to do with compute instruction decoding
caching fetching all of that machinery
has to be there and it doesn't actually
do any real work it just moves data
around so it's an inefficient way to
solve any problem but it is a great
sales pitch it's an inefficient way to
solve any problem right it's really easy
to take I can take a 10 year old kid and
teach him to write Python and do stuff
in Minecraft they're doing that now
right I certainly can't take a tenure
kid and teach him how to build a
flip-flop right so hardware design is
hard
software design is easy this model has
worked up until this point but we're
running into fundamental limitations of
the hardware at max eller we promote a
different model of computing what we
call the data flow model this is also a
very old idea in computer science it was
just never really realizable in a real
way until until more recently in the
data flow model instead of treating data
like it's static we treat data like it's
moving constantly and that means all of
that machinery do that is to go fetch
data and bring it back that goes away we
don't need that anymore and instead of
computing in time by running through a
list of instructions what we do is
compute in space we take the actual
physical surface of our silicon we
arrange the compute we want to do in
space across it and we flow the data
through it to actually do the
computation the advantage of the this is
we're not wasting silicon and machinery
that doesn't actually do work right so
we can squeeze a lot more compute into a
little tiny chip and we're also not
wasting clock cycles right so when
you're when a if I write a piece of code
and I want to know how fast it runs in a
control flow system there's only one way
to know that's actually run it because
there's all kinds of variables I don't
know about the operating system to
caching I go get something from data
maybe that takes ten cycles if it's
right there in a cache maybe it takes
thousands if I have to go and get it
from Ram or even from a disk right so in
a data flow model the very next piece of
data is going to arrive with the very
next clock cycle so every single clock
cycle gets used to compute so tell you a
little bit about max seller is a company
right max seller began here at Stanford
with our founders research in the late
to late 90s completers PhD in 2000 was
that under you or was that just you were
Mike Flynn okay it's under Mike Flynn
who is now one of our chair our chairman
of our board you take the credit but not
the blame okay so it started here at
Stanford
I took it to Bell Labs for a couple
years and then bought out his research
project and started a company Mac seller
in 2003 we have had clients in oil and
gas
Chevron II and I Schlumberger we've had
clients in finance JP Morgan CME Group
Citigroup we also have clients and
defense and cybersecurity and we have a
number of strategic technology
partnerships with companies like Juniper
Hitachi and AWS
so tell you that a couple of our
success stories real quick with this
technology before we dive into how it
works
so one of our earliest ones was a
chevron chevron takes these big boats
out and if you see this boat it's
trailing thousands of seismic sensors
and they take it out they shoot an air
gun into the water they get feeds back
on all those sensors and then they have
to run a really big 3d finite-difference
model to basically piece out from that
data where the oil is what they were
doing was taking this boat out shooting
things collecting a whole bunch of data
sending it back to a data center
processing it getting it back and of
course the boat by that point is no
longer over where it was and if you want
to turn it around and go survey the same
area that's a big overhead to do that so
we actually worked with them to develop
data flow as a way to address that
performance density problem to bring
more compute as close as possible to
where those data is being actually
collected another client of ours JP
Morgan and the financial crisis you know
as you as I'm sure many of you know at
complex credit derivatives were very
hard to compute during the financial
crisis people didn't care before the
financial crisis because they were seen
as having no risk but afterwards it was
a big deal
we stepped in with JP Morgan and took
one of their risk calculations from
eight hours to two minutes on our boxes
so they were also very happy with us
and then finally Juniper Networks is one
of our technology partnerships we've
actually released a commercial product
with them the qfx 5100 this is a
top-of-rack switch so in a in a data
center you've got a rack of servers and
at the top generally speaking all your
connections go through a top of rack
switch that then goes out to the rest of
the network we have a top rack switch
with one of our data flow chips in it
that can be programmed using our
software and basically what that does is
if you're a data center you have data
coming in and you need to do some kind
of compute if maybe you're a bank you
need to do risk metrics maybe you're
some kind of institution as regulatory
requirements where you need to stamp
time stamp packets
things like that we can capture that
data and process on it at line rate as
fat at 40 gig e hundred GigE whatever's
coming in we can process so how do we
build this how do we actually build a
data flow computer and so the next
section I'll kind of talk you through
the process and then I'm going to go
through a specific example that I've
actually worked on so it starts by
understanding our algorithm this is
really the biggest thing at max eller
right control flow is how 99% of all
programming works it's how 99% of all
programmers thing
and in order for me to take my problem
and build the data flow computer around
it the first thing I have to do is
rethink the problem in terms of data
flow that's really where most of the
work goes in it's where the thought work
right there after the technology takes
over so this is really the tricky part
once I understand my algorithm the next
thing I'm going to do is I'm gonna start
writing in our java base language max J
so whenever I tell people to say look I
mean go you do high-performance
computing in Java
are you nuts well no we don't actually
run the Java right what the Java does is
it describes the calculation we want to
run and then when we run that Java it
builds the computer that does that
calculation so the Java itself is not
actually what we run at runtime it's
just a design language that's all it is
once we've designed the the written the
Java we can put that into our Max
compiler which runs that Java and
assembles the graph and what we get is a
data flow graph so this image over here
on the right and I'll go into this in a
little bit more detail in a moment but
this what we call a data flow graph
right as inputs at the top operations
and then it filters down to an output at
the bottom what I can do with that data
flow graph once I've assembled it is I
can run it as though it were an actual
computer now I'm only simulating but if
you've ever played with a hardware
simulator you simulate a lot of things
right you simulate bit by bit signal by
signal clock switch by clocks which I
don't have to do nearly as much to
simulate a graph right it I have a graph
that says add two things together all I
have to do is loop through two arrays
and add them together it's much easier
to simulate so I write my max J I build
my graph I test my graph and then I have
all the standard software development
tools I can do debugging I can do unit
testing if I don't like what it does I
go back and write some more max J and I
keep doing that until I'm happy with the
code that it's running in simulation
once I'm happy with the code it's
running in simulation then I'm gonna
take it and run the hardware build and
the hardware builds intensive at the
moment I don't know if we have full
support for any language but the plan is
to skin whatever language people want
right I mean we can do it in Python week
and it's easy to put skin layers on top
of that no we're just building an object
model so I'm building a graph I don't
care
fish it the memory model is or knew that
because it's not what I actually run I
just need to be able to build a model of
objects and the connections between them
well there's static cuz they get burned
into the chat basically right so the
data moves dynamically through them but
I can't take my graph and the chip that
I've already burned basically a chip
that I've already laid it on to and then
say yeah I want a MUX there right I mean
it I can do that in code but it's a lot
you know I have to go through the
hardware build process again to actually
get it out so I take a little bit more
of a close look at what that actual
coding language looks like right so this
is a very simple example what I have is
a very simple calculation where I'm
taking a stream of data in at the top
and I want to do a moving average right
so I have a stream of data and I want to
take three adjacent elements add them
together and divide by three really
really really basic so the way I need to
do that in code is I start by defining
an input so I have this first line up
here x equals i/o dot input and that
creates that little house at the top of
my data flow graph it's just saying I
have an employed and thereafter I just
have lines where I create new variables
from the old variables with formulas
equations multiplications additions all
the standard you know things that I
would have in the scientific code or the
engineer ago or whatever I was copying
over right any kind of formula I could
pretty much copy and paste it into Java
right but what I'm doing with those
calculations is when I run this it's not
actually there's no number there for pre
even X and next and things like that
it's building this graph it's saying
that these things saying pre plus X plus
next equals some means that those three
lines have to be connected by addition
operators to come out with a new line
that sort of thing very much like tensor
flow very similar concept right so if
you've ever worked in tensor flow you
start with this sort of tensor object
and then you do operations on it you get
other tensor objects that's effectively
what this is so very very similar kind
of concept and what's nice about this is
because it's code and because it's
object-oriented code so I also have the
advantage of polymorphism and whatever
other kind of sort of tricks I want to
play I can build really complex graphs
with relatively simple code so this is a
graph this is 4,600 nodes
in a graph of a 3d finite difference
time step now if I showed you the code
that generates this you'd be able to
read it it'd be you know this element
plus that times this it's a formula
right but when you actually expand out
all the different data dependencies and
connections in that graph it's a very
big complicated graph and we can build
that with very simple code that's really
the the benefit of Max J and the Max
compiler so okay now we've got our graph
we know the calculation we want to do
now I need to actually physically build
a machine to do it right up to this
point all I have done is abstractly
defined a machine right and that's
important that's really where the most
of the effort goes into is abstractly
defining my dataflow computer but how do
I actually get performance out I don't
actually build it so the first thing I
need is an actual physical
representation of the data flow graph so
I need a chip and on that chip I'm gonna
have the silicon actually arranged into
so for example the individual compute
nodes will be pieces of logic right and
then the lines connecting those nodes
are actual wires that flow the data from
one of those Centers of the silicon to
others so I have an actual physical
representation of my data flow graph on
my data flow chip and that's what my
data is going to flow through the rest
of the data flow engine is places for
the data to flow to and for the data to
flow from so for example one place I
might want to flow data to and from is
from PCIe right so I want to be able to
talk to a CPU that's running basically
like a C you know just basic C code and
I wanna be able to send data to the card
and get data back from the card just
like I would with any kind of
accelerator right so I have pcie express
I want to talk to it and we have a an
API called Mac cell or OS that handles
all of the low-level details all the
driver and the you know the individual
running of pins and all that so you
literally say here's my data in CPU
memory run this calculation on it very
very basic another place I might want to
have data flow to and from is memory on
the actual board so I'll talk a little
bit about our memory hierarchy in a
minute we call this L mem right large
these are usually ddr4 dims we can fit
so like the latest generation we fit
three of them on a board we could do 32
gigs so that's like 96 games for example
of potentially Ram
and again that goes directly into the
chip so there's a little different than
other accelerators right the the the CPU
does not talk to that memory it talks to
the chip right and the chip talks to
that memory and I can implement the
memory controller on the chip and that's
how I can get data to and from memory
but it all goes through the chip another
thing I might want to do is talk to
other DFAS all right if I can't get all
the work done in one data flow engine
then I want to communicate with other
ones I need an interconnect the latest
generation that's an optical
interconnect it's a bi-directional
interconnect to two other cards so I can
do it like a ring topology for example
where I could put four cards in a ring
and each one can communicate out and
back to its two neighbours nearest to it
in the ring and again that goes straight
into the chip that's not mediated by an
OS or a CPU or anything like that and
then the last thing I might want to do
is talk to a network so I can actually
put an external QF SP on the board and I
can put ten Giggy hundred Giggy
basically whatever I can by the IP core
four or Aang because they cost more
money for you know 100 Giggy but then I
can take network traffic either I can
take just I can capture like TCP IP
traffic or I can talk to network storage
all of that at a much higher rate than I
get from the PCIe so generally when
people come to us and they say I've got
data and I want to get to it faster than
I can get through PCIe network is
usually the next place we'll go for that
so this is what one looks like in real
life right this is a box that we have
this a 1u blade so if you've been in a
data center so 19 inch some-odd wide
blade it's about an inch and a half high
eight of those cards will fit in it so
why eight I mean you certainly can't fit
like eight GPUs and one you blade and
the reason for that is these things
operate at very low frequencies hundred
two hundred megahertz they generate very
little heat the cooling system is
literally it's just a block of copper
that we blow air over there's no water
none of that fancy stuff right so we can
stack a lot of them in a very small
space that one you blade will hold eight
data flow engines up to a terabyte of
RAM split out among those data flow
engines all of them of course
interconnected to each other with that
max ring interconnect and then we also
have what's essentially a virtualized
PCIe connection right so I take this
thing I put it in a big rack I connect
it to an InfiniBand switch
and then if I have a CPU node connected
to InfiniBand switch I say to that on
the CPU note I say here's an IP address
give me for da face and this thing will
allocate me the DfE s and then map them
as though they're just available via
PCIe so in these generally we say like
in the equivalent performance to 2250
x86 servers it's hard to gauge
performance and we'll talk about this as
we get into later because it just
depends on the problem right for some
problems it's gonna be a massive
improvement some it's it's you know
gonna be more moderate so it really just
comes down to what the problem is that
we're trying to port that's why there's
a wide range on that number so I'll go
through a specific example right this is
one I've been working on for the last
year or so quantum espresso this is part
of a larger project for price the
partnership for Advanced Computing in
Europe and they've asked us to port for
applications this is the one that was
assigned to me basically what this is is
it's a Fortran it's an old Fortran
software package or a series of Fortran
software packages yes I had to learn
Fortran for this exercise that was fun I
actually don't I don't complain about it
too much
what it is I won't go through all the
physics and the details of the
calculation but basically it's an
iterative solve I have this really large
system I need to do a whole bunch of
linear algebra and FFTs and and I'm
going to start with a guess and I'm
going to iterate until that guessed
converges to some you know fixed point
basically the reference that they gave
us was eight system tantalum oxide and
it took two full racks of blue-jean q so
if you've ever seen Blue Gene command
these things are the size of a
refrigerator - two of those six point
seven cubic meters of space and I looked
this up by the way a typical domestic
refrigerators about a cubic meter so
that's six or seven refrigerators worth
32,000 cores 53 minutes of wall time and
it used 384 kilowatts of power and by
comparison like a typical house is a
couple of kilowatts so that's you know
the size of a couple refrigerators uses
a couple kilowatts can we beat that so
the first thing we do right we unpack
our Fortran software package and we
start doing what you do with any kind of
software you trying to prove we profile
it right so for data flow we're looking
for something a little bit different
most profiling tools focus on function
calls right function calls are akin
trol flow concept I have a sequence of
instructions and what a function call
basically is is a jump to kind of
instruction right you're at this point
go to that point so that means I can
have reusable logic I can have some
section of code that I can run over and
over and over again
and it runs essentially independent of
the context it's called in I could run
it a thousand times I could run it one
time it doesn't know it's just an
independent piece of logic that's
control flow we don't have that
advantage and data flow or data flow we
think about loops we think about the
major loops the order that those
functions get called in and we think
about the amount of data that flows into
and out of those loops so we generally
build something like this this is a loop
flow diagram for quantum espresso again
I won't go through the physics but the
basic idea is there's really three major
loops in this program and if you go
through the functions you'll find them
eventually right there there's one loop
and then okay the other loop is in the
function that it calls and that kind of
thing but once you've mapped out the
logic it's really easy to see how the
program itself actually works right so
in this case for corner expresso we
focused on that innermost loop that FFT
loop right so this outermost loop runs a
couple dozen times the middle loop runs
a couple hundred times the inner loop
runs a couple thousand times and one of
the things we notice about the inner
loop says two inputs has this I input
the vrs input and it turns out the
tsiyon put is pretty big the vrs inputs
pretty small and it doesn't change very
much so those are just you know really
big ok positive things for acceleration
the other thing is that if you think
about the amount of internal memory it
would have to generate to run through
that whole five gigabytes it'd be
something more like 250 gigabytes now in
real life you wouldn't really allocate
that you break into little pieces but if
you think about that is like a total
memory requirement it's a lot more
memory in the loop than going into and
out of the loop that's a prime indicator
that's a key target for acceleration so
again on a control flow system we break
that into batches we'd say all right
here's my five gigabyte problem break
that into a bunch of hundred megabyte
problems move 100 megabyte problem into
memory do everything I need to do
grab the result back then move the next
one it's a shift kind of thing for data
flow I run all of them at once right I
just run the first one and I just keep
going
so once I've done my loop flow graph the
next thing I need to think about is
where I want to actually put things in
memory so I talked a little bit earlier
we have a two-tier memory hierarchy
right we have fmm which is memory that's
on the chip the fast memory so I tell
people this is kind of like l1 cache I
mean that only in terms of speed it has
the speed of l1 cache it's not a cache
in any kind of sense what it is is
allocatable memory units on the chip
that I can grab that I can put an
address on them and then I can pull data
out of them every clock cycle so every
single clock cycle input can pull memory
from a different address in my F mem so
there's no like okay dive send out the
request and then I wait a couple hundred
cycles and then it comes back it's
literally just this cycle that data the
next cycle that there's also Elm ml mem
is those on board dims and for those
obviously I have communication I have to
go through a memory controller I have to
talk to the the dims I have to get the
data out and so for that obviously it's
slower but it's much larger I can fit up
to 96 gigs and that's it it's it's a
much simpler memory hierarchy than say a
GPU so in quantum espresso for example
this cube that I need to do 3d FFT over
there's that there's a cube and I'm
basically going to do 3d FFT do a
multiplication do 3d FFT back and if I
look at it from a data flow perspective
I'm going to need to do two things I'm
going to need to do all the
multiplications and additions everything
that goes in the FFT that part is easy
really really easy
it's multiplications and additions right
the other thing is reordering the data I
have to reorder the data within the FFT
and then I have to reorder the data when
I'm doing transposes so for example if I
have a plane and I'm reading across it
one way I have to store that in memory
and then read it out the other way so
where I do those transposes depends upon
the size of my memory the plane that I
would need to do the 2d transposon is
about half a megabyte I've got 40
megabytes available on the chip so
obviously I'm going to do all those
transposes in fmm on the chip the whole
cube itself is too big to do that the
whole cube 128 Meg's so when I want to
do 3d transposes which is where I've
basically reading the cube like this and
then I have to read the whole thing in
before I can start to read across it in
the slow dimension
right so for those I have to actually
send it out to Elm em and then get it
back I can't fit it on the chat another
thing that I noticed this is a really
really just fun problem for this
particular type of thing because I'm not
starting with the entire cube filled in
I only start with a little sphere that's
actually only about five six percent of
the total area of the cube I mean an fft
across the whole domain but i'm only
care about putting that sphere in and i
only care about the values that end up
in that sphere on the way out so that
makes it a lot easier it means that the
amount of data that needs to move to and
from the board is just about 6% of the
cube the amount of data that has to move
to and from those large dims is about
50% of the cube so there's about ten
times more data that has to move to mmm
that works out pretty nicely because the
bandwidth between the DfE and el mem is
about ten times higher than the
bandwidth between the DfE and PCIe right
so I have a sort of natural fit once
I've identified where I want to put my
memory in my data flow then I start
laying out my actual flow my
architecture so in this case for example
I'm going to start with my input data on
the CPU I'm gonna feed it into the FFT
in the first dimension I'm gonna do a
transpose and you see that's talking to
F mem on the chip then I'm gonna go to
the F of T in the second dimension then
I have to go out to memory get it back
do the FFT in the third dimension
multiplication and then undo the whole
process right now the thing you notice
about this is that it's one continuous
pipeline from beginning to end right so
I have side goes all the way out to H
side so if you think about this like a
pipeline think about it like an oil
pipeline right if I want to send a
barrel of oil on an oil pipeline I don't
put one barrel in it send it all the way
to the end and then once it gets out put
the second barrel in alright I can feed
data in as soon as the pipe is empty
even if data hasn't started coming out
the other end of the pipe so I could
have the first cube go in and be working
its way through down here somewhere and
already be feeding the second cubes
worth of data in alright so that's a
huge advantage over control flow
architectures where what I'm gonna have
to do is move the first cubes data out
into memory do everything I need to do
and only when everything is done all my
threads are synchronized and all that
but then I can move it back and start
the second one here it's a pipeline as
soon as the first one goes in the second
one starts going even if the first one
hasn't come out the other thing that's
nice again as I pointed out the widths
of these arrows indicate roughly how
much data is flowing in and out and you
can see that there's a lot more data
moving between the DfE in the memory
than there is between the DfE and the
CPU and it matches the bandwidth which
is very nice now you get if you think
about this more control flow
architecture I don't really control this
at all this is going to be dependent on
what my cache can do right so I might
have the same kind of bandwidth
limitation but I don't have the ability
to use it in an extremely optimal way so
what does this look like in real life
that's what the chip actually looks like
when I take that data flow graph and I
build it out this is a tool we have
called aerial view and what this does is
it takes every individual little logic
cell on that chip and highlights it to
indicate what part of the calculation it
got put in so if you go back to this
architecture diagram there's really five
compute kernels right those light blue
circles one two three four five compute
kernels I have a look at this picture
there's five shaded regions one two
three four five those are those five
compute currents right just in that
eight thing on the left and I'll show
you what the other two are in a moment
so if I actually overlay the data flow
on top of this it makes a little bit
more sense right so this shaded region
up here in the top right that's my first
FFT the data comes in from PCIe the PCI
he's not like literally on top of the
chip there's pins and things like that
but it's just for a diagram right data
comes in and goes around goes the memory
controller back out goes to this kernel
guy and works its way back up and all
that happens literally physically in
space so all five of these regions are
running all the time and the only
difference between what they're
computing is what stage they're at the
ones that are later in the pipeline are
doing later data than the ones that are
before but they're all working on data
all the time every clock cycle now the
other two sections of the chip they're
just more silicon right this particular
chip comes in three pieces they
basically the way they're building these
now is they make up die and then they
just kind of copy it three times right
they're called SLRs is something single
logic regions or something like
there's three of them on the chip and it
turns out that when I do this whole
pipeline it fits in one of them pretty
well
which means what do i do I just copy and
paste try to go back to that old trick
so this now actually has three copies of
that and then you can't really see it
from these diagrams but the individual
kernels themselves are actually double
width as well they handle two input
streams and two output streams so all
told this is actually six pipes so not
only am i doing every stage of the pipe
simultaneously but if I have six pipes
all six pipes and all stages in those
pipes are running simultaneously so what
is actually translate to in terms of
performance how does this actually
perform so first of all we have to kind
of caveat things right which is the way
you think about performance and data
flow is going to be very very different
than the way you think about it in
control flow and control flow we think
about performance in terms of runtime
right I hit the button I run it I get
any answer out at the end right the
reason that works for control flow is
were reusing the hardware all right so
if I have one core I run something it
takes 10 seconds running it ten times
takes a hundred seconds because I can't
reuse that hardware while the first
one's running right so we think in terms
of runtime for data flow we think more
in terms of throughput we think in terms
of the rate at which it's processing the
data I think of this as let you think of
the analogy is like at your water faucet
at home right when you open your water
faucet at home you don't care how long
an individual molecule of water took to
get from the water tower to your faucet
that's completely irrelevant information
to you what matters is the flow of the
water how much water is actually coming
out when you pull it out so we have to
think about it in terms of flow and when
we try to figure out the performance of
one of these systems we have to break
out a very sophisticated technical tool
called a pocket calculator right that's
one of the one of the weird things about
this technology is actually realizing
the data flow Computers a lot of work
but estimating how it's going to perform
is really trivially easy and that's
because I don't have any of the cash or
operating system kind of overhead and
mechanics and pieces that I don't
understand and 15 different
architectures I'm trying to support and
different compilers do different things
I don't have to worry about any of that
I know exactly how it works I know
exactly what the throughput is so in
this case we think about that in terms
of three potential choke points right we
think about that in terms of first of
all PCIe right I have to be able to move
the data from the chip to the D
hey and that's a simple calculation I
sit down and I say alright every cube
needs to move seven megabytes of data I
can get three gigabytes a second I do a
simple division 433 cubes a second
really really really basic just I mean
literally it's an Excel spreadsheet did
we do this then it's okay that's so that
PCIe will move 433 cubes a second I can
do the same kind of calculation with the
Elm em right the mm I have to move a lot
more data but I have a lot higher
bandwidth and I work out the calculation
and okay that one moves 250 the last
piece is compute right I have to know
how fast I can actually compute the data
in between those two places and so for
that I need to think about clock cycles
and clock frequency I need to know how
fat basically how many clock cycles it
takes to do a cube and how many clock
cycles I get a second so it's easy to
work that out the the FFTs consume four
elements every clock cycle
there's 16 million elements into cube
therefore four million clock cycles per
cube 150 million clock cycles a second
and then you multiply everything by 6
because there's those six pipes right so
all the throughput is just multiplied by
6 and that comes to 215 cubes a second
so obviously it's easy enough to look at
this and see where the bottleneck is
meant the minimum of these three things
is 215 therefore my data flow computer
will do 215 cubes a second now I don't
know how long one cube takes all right I
don't know how long it takes to put in
one cube and wait for it to come out but
I know if I have to run 200 or so it's
going to take about a second now by
comparison how does a reference system
handle well that big refrigerator the
six refrigerators or whatever put
together one rack of blue-jean
so half that system that's about three
hundred and thirty cubes a second so
this is one board one PCIe backplane
that does basically half of what a Blue
Gene a full Blue Gene rack does so if
you if you kind of think about that
performance scaled up to a full size
system right so this is a picture of the
Blue Gene itself one rack three some odd
cubic meters of three refrigerators
roughly speaking powers 192 is half that
384 and that only does 338 cubes a
second for that 1u rack remember I can
fit eight dia fees in it so if one DfE
does 215 eight of them do 1700 right so
it's quite a lot of quite a lot in that
1u rack
but each board only uses about a hundred
to two hundred watts mate at most so
it's much lower power remember what is
most of the volume of that blue-jean
it's not silicon well not most of it
probably is silicon but there's also a
lot of it that's just literally water
there's a tank of water in this thing
that circulates through as no doesn't do
any computing at all it just is water
right everything in that 1u box is
compute every last little bit of it so
what you see over that is there's no we
don't need all the water cooling we
don't need all the communication that's
the other thing is if you look inside
this blue gene it's a ton of
communication because that FFT is split
out into 256 pieces and gets done on 256
separate cores we don't have any of that
communication we they're optically
connected but I'm actually using that
for this it's air cooled it's literally
like a block a copper on top of a board
and it's just way more power efficient
so if you work it all out it comes out
to 700 times more efficient at this one
task in terms of the amount of compute I
can do per say cubic meter and a
thousand times more efficient in terms
the amount of compute I can do per watt
right now the big caveat there is this
is just one part of the computing task
right just that FFT but it's still not
the same as like if you took a GPU
saying oh oh well I can do the compute
at five teraflops
but the PCIe slows me down no that's
literally how fast it'll go right at
that task so that's basically that the
box itself is 135 times smaller but it
does five times as much so if you take
five times huh yeah basically five times
135 is 700 I do what so so a big part of
this is we've got to get people to
invest the time and energy into
converting things to data flow right and
to do that we have to express what
they're gonna get out of it in some kind
of real terms so we usually do that in
terms of compute in space you know if
you think about it I've limited space
the data center I've limited amount of
power I've limited amount of cooling
capacity and what I rather get you know
one of those or maybe say 20 of those
and stick them in a rack and have the
equivalent of 20 racks of blue-jean all
right if I can do that
it's a lot more power in space efficient
yeah so we usually think of these things
in terms of compute per space and
compute per power because again it's a
different paradigm if we think if we'd
say in terms of runtime right it's the
least meaning meaningful metric it's
really more about throughput space and
power some customers want to reduce
space yes I'll tell you in this case why
time is not one of them right and that's
because I've got a nom de long problem
with my with this algorithm there's a
good fifth of it that's just not
parallelized at all so even if I make
the rest of it run a hundred times
faster I only get 5x so from the
beginning I've said let's think about
this less in terms of okay I'm gonna get
you one X and run time it's gonna run
just as fast it's just not going to be
the size of six refrigerators it's gonna
be the size of you know something you
can put on a desk so that's why in this
case space and power but for other
clumps of customers absolutely so for JP
Morgan for example they didn't care
about space and power they cared about
runtime they cared about okay I've got
this thing runs in eight hours and
that's just long enough to be useless
from a business perspective that means I
can find out tomorrow how much money I
lost today whereas two minutes is just
enough for me to actually manage a
business to it so some customers do care
about more about runtime in this
particular instance for quantum espresso
I've been focused this project is also
focused on energy efficiency that's
really what the the price pre
procurement process what they're looking
at is building exascale sort of scale
computers that are energy efficient so
they're looking at 50x look for better
well good tonight you've made too many
iterations to do your eigen
decomposition so try analyze first and
then the iterations are much less so I
think in a lot of cases obviously we do
look for changes in the algorithm I mean
that's one of the things that's very
different from from ICANN decomposition
yes so I did decomposition so pick an
opening the fits your occupation so in
this case we're doing things in a way
lower level in the actual eigen problem
because for this particular one
that's more than nine to five in them oh
yeah there's the second level which is I
just I haven't gonna do it we'll talk
afterwards I'll show you there's a
second level but basically there's two
sides of this there's linear algebra and
there's FFT if we make the FFT run
really fast but not the linear algebra
we get nothing out of it in large-scale
T's more about actually computing the
matrix product itself it's not about the
actual okay yes we've looked at a lot of
algorithmic ways to change this okay so
okay so the final thing is right now
I've got my actual data flow computer
built how do I actually deliver it how
do I get it in the hands of the people
that want to use it how do i integrate
it with the Fortran how do I get it to
be a working piece of software so what
the max compiler does after you write
your max J and you run it through you do
your hardware build what it's going to
give you is a binary file that contains
the actual structure of the chip right
the binary that's actually going to get
loaded onto the chip itself and it wraps
that in an API it's the C API and it
handles all the low-level details all of
the you know the driver in P you know
talking by PCI and all that so what you
end up with is basically a shared object
file it's very big because it has all
that binary data in it and you have a
header and the header has just C
functions right so I can integrate that
into anything I can integrate C into and
the function calls are very simple it's
they doesn't have that need to copy
things from host memory to device memory
it's like literally I just give it a
host memory pointer and off it goes and
I've actually structured this so that I
will be able to point it at the memory
natively allocated by Fortran I've
literally just there's where Fortran
keeps its memory the data is already in
the order that you want it in its padded
the way you want it and it'll go grab it
straight from that address in memory and
send it over the PCIe so we call that
the simple live CPU the slick interface
so it's really a much easier interface
to use I think even than other
accelerators we also call that this the
S API the single device API we generally
have multiple layers of those API so
we'll generally have like a middleware
type
err that divides up the problem handles
inter communication between the devices
we call that the multiple device API or
the EM API and basically the idea there
is it just like allocates the problem
splits it into pieces and then the final
kind of API that's gonna be very unique
to us is what we call the device API so
this is okay now I've solved one problem
with max J and I have an existing
working data flow computer and now I
want to solve a very similar problem
with a little tiny tweak and like I said
it's not a dynamic graph so if I make
that tweak I'm gonna have to go through
the build process again but because
everything is built in these in this Max
J's Java like language it's all object
oriented it's in a jar somewhere I can
basically go grab that jar pick a couple
pieces out of it assemble them and get a
working data flow computer that's what
we call the dapi right is is where
you're working with pre-built
Max J components at a much higher level
so now I'll kind of move into this
portion of the talk I want to talk about
a broader spectrum of the things that we
have done outside just a specific
quantum espresso project so the best way
to see that is that this address app
gallery dot max seller comm slash
hashtag for some reason this is our App
Gallery this is the world's largest
collection of data flow applications
which is it may also be the world's only
collection of data flow applications I'm
not sure but but there's a lot there and
it covers a lot of our science use cases
so you can see like just from this
screenshot right I mean there's things
like the brain Network there's there's
physics there's just straight computer
science packet capture imaging there's
lots of different examples a lot of
where this comes from is we have interns
that come in to work with us for summer
and they'll put together a project and
put something in the app gallery I think
there's something like 40 some-odd
applications and a lot of them have
source code that you can look at as well
here's an example of that sort of next
level right which is all right data flow
computing is awesome for computer
science people but we want to put data
flow computing in the hands of regular
science people right that have a problem
they want to solve but they don't want
to spend time learning how computers
actually work right so so a good example
of this finite difference right we do a
lot of finite difference work one of the
reasons finite difference
worked really well for our technology is
because of that mmm if you think about
finite difference way it usually works
is I have an element and to update that
element I need to look at elements
around me and that doesn't work really
well when you have a strictly data
parallel architecture right so if I have
an architecture where I have okay this
node right here or this CPU or core
whatever is doing a calculation on this
element and it needs to get data from a
nearby element a lot of times there's a
hierarchy right like sometimes if it's
if it's just the nearest thread I can
grab it from a register but maybe if
it's in a different part of the chip I
need to go through shared memory or you
know there's hierarchies and there's
halos and all this kind of stuff right
for us what's nice is we can keep a
really big window right there in memory
on the chip and that window is really
just represented as different points in
that stream of data right so if I think
about my window the element to my right
is just the next element in my stream of
data the element to my left is the
previous element the element above me is
maybe you know five hundred elements
previous that kind of thing so finite
difference translates really well and
this was one of the first problems that
we worked on for the oil and gas
industry they had to run these really
big 3d finite difference models at some
point we said all right there's a lot of
these geosciences have these equations
they want to test they don't want to
learn max J they just want to write
equations so what we built was max
jennife D max jennife T takes Java where
the science user literally just writes
their equations they define what their
stencil is and then they say my update
equation is update at time T is this
element at time T minus 1 times this
factor plus whatever right they write
their equation for the finite difference
and our layer on top of that does all of
the generates the max J it does all of
the Halo figures out all the sharing
when I do need to split this in two
separate DF es it does all that
mechanically it figures out how to
decompose based on how many deities
there are all that all those details get
handled by the the max gen of D so the
science teacher puts in the equations
and gets out the results really really
basic stuff so this was was very popular
with the oil and gas industry in
particular this is one of my favorites
this is an actual academic peer-reviewed
publication where they measured our
speed-up over a similar sized box right
so these numbers these 19 X 14 X are
comparisons on a 1u to 1/u basis and
what I like about these numbers is this
is a real
straight so this is not a theoretical
model this is not a you know an Excel
model or whatever this is literally you
know timed from beginning to end and the
same kind of setup running the same kind
of algorithm that kind of thing and you
see just this massive speed-up over both
the CPU and the GPU versions of this
right so even if I take that one you
know and I start sticking a Fermi or a
Kepler GPU in it I get okay it's one and
a half is two three X better right
because I still have to deal with that
issue of sharing memory and all of these
things getting that strict data
parallelism just doesn't completely
magically change my world there but when
I go to the MPC X Box again same size
box same physical space in the data
center it's 19 X faster than that CPU
bases instead of just three and the last
one machine learning because everybody
has to do machine right we this has
really been a push in the last year or
so for us one of the there's a couple of
advantages to this hardware for machine
learning right one of them is just
generally speaking any kind of algorithm
where I'm doing a lot of very simple
computation in bulk is great for data
flow right the more branching the more
divergence the more I sort of do some
calculations sometimes some calculation
other times that kind of stuff gets less
efficient for data flow because what I
end up doing is essentially building two
data flow computers side by side and
then muxing their outputs together right
so basically they're both running all
the time but one of them the data is
just getting thrown away all right it's
not very efficient but if I just know
I'm gonna go through this kind of
multiplication just a gajillion times
you know billion times over this
multiplication in some orderly fashion
that's perfect for us right because we
just flow right over it but the other
advantage is that because we're
designing the hardware we're not limited
to the specific types are not limited to
integer types floating-point types I can
do fixed point types I can do two bits
if I want to do right so I can change
the precision of my machine learning
sort of calculation to whatever is you
know sort of the lowest precision I can
get that's still reasonable and get the
maximum amount of performance out of it
and the other advantage is just we have
a huge amount of memory right it's very
hard now to buy a GPU they're starting
to make them now that have more of you
know that 1030 whatever gigs but
but for the most part you do ones Uganda
is about twelve right you usually get
about twelve and that limits your model
right I can only put so many weights I
can only do so much training data
because I'm limited in what I can put in
that memory we have more memory but we
also again have that ability to process
massive amounts of data by just flowing
it through in time right so I can do
essentially my flow my data in do my
training in my inference all
continuously so I'm actually updating
the weights while I'm using the weights
continuously and and have it flow out
and you can see here this is some some
misses a fairly old when we need to
update this but you can see that there's
performance comparison this is eight of
our last generation that's six pipes at
16-bit and comparing that to two GPUs
eyes let me see what is that about 10x
performance in terms of training time
and in terms of energy as well
and then obviously training energy is a
big thing now right I mean if I'm you
know trying to do machine learning on a
very very large data set and I'm gonna
run a very large data center over it for
a long time then I really do start to
care about things like compute per space
and compute for power that's it for me
um so what open it up for do we open it
up for Q&A now or do we do that
afterwards okay yeah absolutely so I'll
open up for questions because we're
using XA we're upgrading to X 16 now so
that yeah that's just a hardware and
that's true for a lot of this really is
that it's just kind of up to what
generation hardware same thing with the
Ethernet port where we've never actually
done 100 GigE it's not because we can't
it's because to do it somebody would
have to be willing to pay for the IP
core and would actually need it we just
haven't had the need for it yet so same
thing with PCI you like that we when we
move to x16 will get the same PCI
bandwidth that you get for x16 it's just
we're using x8 now
yes what can you tell us about the part
where the the chip on to which these
things map how is how are these
developed what are you using
what's the programming technique to what
extent is very actually burning silicon
as opposed to downloading the way you
would for an FPGA or something well it's
an FPGA emulator basically so what it is
it's an FPGA chip and we convert our
data flow graph into VHDL and then we
pass that over to the vendor design
tools so you'll notice by the way I
managed to make it what do we now info
almost to the full hour right and I have
not said the word FPGA yet that so but
you notice that yes there's a reason for
that
I'm not supposed to say well you know I
and I'll explain why right first what
we're not an FPGA computing company
we're dataflow computing company part of
that's obviously a marketing thing but
really what really what it comes down to
is dataflow an FPGA are two different
concepts right FPGA is reconfigurable
Hardware a lot of people use FPGAs for
control flow right they basically build
smaller cores or things but they're
still running instructions and stuff
like that so FPGA is not the same
concept as dataflow and vice-versa
dataflow doesn't technically require
FPGAs it's not the only kind of hardware
that theoretically could represent our
data photograph it's just right now it's
the most accessible one so yeah so the
way it works at the low level is we take
that graph we convert it to VHDL and
there you're thinking through all of the
pipelining all of the timing all of the
scheduling all of those details get
handled by the compiler it takes the
VHDL and generates it and then we pass
that the vendor tools the vendor tools
are what actually give us the binaries
that we can then load onto the chip and
then when we go to load them that's all
loaded in software so I have that I have
the chip sitting on the board it takes
about a tenth of a second to load them
so for example it's possible to do
things like design a processor and okay
maybe at the beginning of my calculation
I don't need 64-bit accuracy I can do 32
bed and then oh I reach a point where
32-bit is just not converging anymore
I'm down to that 32nd bit in terms of
accuracy and I say okay I want to do
better I just switch it out with a
64-bit processor like that take the old
one off drop the new one on in software
and it's all that's all handled with
those c.a.p
my calls so the latest generation of our
boards is the vertex ultra scale 9 plus
from sitelinks but we've actually
alternated we've used eye links and
we've used Altera again that's the
benefit right is that we want people
thinking about their problem in an
abstract way in terms of data flow we
don't want people thinking about
Hardware implementation details we do
all that so if you've written your
application and data flow for our Altera
boards and you say ok well I want to do
that on as I links board you can go
ahead and do that it's it you take the
same high level code and just compile it
basically for a different Orca texture
but we've extracted all those details
way and we use just basically whatever
is the best chip on the market so I mean
we're gonna have the same kind of
congestion problems that you're gonna
have generally routing the hardware
right so a lot of it comes down to the
vendor tools you know how good they are
at handling the congestion and sometimes
the problem is not solvable and you have
to lower the frequency and things like
that but the advantage there I think if
you look at a graph like this right so
you're talking about there was I it's
this one right yeah and you can see like
there are a lot of places where I have
these thick bands right and these are
all strictly parallel right these are
operations where they're this is
basically graph is right and it's
putting them all at the same level
because they don't have any dependencies
on each other and these are things I can
physically layout you know side by side
and have them operating in the same
clock cycle but yeah I mean granted a
lot of these crossings are just
artifacts of the way graph is draws the
graph that's a big part of it but yeah I
mean generally speaking if I have these
two kind of wide bands and then there's
a lot of back-and-forth between
different layers that's a congestion
problem it's a routing problem that that
yeah it just comes down to how good the
vendor tools are at solving
so traditional FPGA is like the signings
for Altair whatever that you guys are
using bit level configurable and they've
been that way for a while because they
started out its prototyping tools um but
if you have something like 128 bit bus
that you want you you know around
somewhere in your design which is pretty
common hmm you lose there's a lot of
efficiency that you can just by routing
all those signals individually are you
aware of any vendors they're moving to
sort of a more coarse-grained fpga
architecture or you know I mean I
personally know hey I can't fake an
answer to your questions I know yeah I
mean that's yeah it is fairly coming so
for example in the quantum espresso the
the buses that come out of the memory
controller 512 bit so yeah I mean they
get big and they get congested a big
part of that is one of the things that
we obviously have the advantage to do is
be its bit configurable to the point if
I can literally say I don't want 32-bit
you know I want 31 29 I want 15 you know
whatever is the level that you set and
what's nice when we have this really
high level abstraction is it's easy to
test that mathematically without having
to simulate and build Hardware so I can
say all right I wrote a lot of times
I'll make it a sort of configurable
parameter so I'll say ok the number of
bits that are gonna be used to represent
my data as an input and I can go and
build this whole thing and say that
inputs 32 and I can build the whole
thing and say it's 30 and then I can go
simulate them I can get the answer I
don't have to build any kind of
complicated machinery to figure out
where the 30 or 32 bit will actually
give me the answer with the precision I
want I can go test it but then when I go
to build it in hardware yeah I mean I
have the same kind of hardware
challenges this is more about rethinking
the algorithm and the way that you do
the computation than it is about some
sort of novel solution to the hardware
yes
is like Vegas design without it kind of
thoroughly dropping off so this one is I
think 95 but at the same time it also
doesn't mean yeah no I mean it varies
but again it's the same proper I mean
we're not we don't have our own sort of
hardware tool set or whatever so we're
limited in the same way that the vendor
tools are limited and we're limited to
whatever the hardware they're producing
is but it's so generally speaking 95%
you're pushing it right because you're
using a lot of the logic slices for
routing as well I had that problem with
this and with the way I fixed it right
as I took this and I changed the bit
width so they were more optimized for
the DSPs and when I did that I got a lot
more logic and so it looks like my
utilization is really low but it's using
a lot of the logic for routing and
that's how I'm able to sort of meet
timing but this is a much better picture
to show it cuz the kernels are fatter so
it's just easier to see it's generally
20 gigs a second per dim because it's
ddr4 and and I came over what clock
frequency we run it out is 1200
megahertz and called clock frequency
whatever architecture you've chosen well
so the first thing is if I'm getting
memory if I'm getting data from the host
to the device it doesn't have to go
through memory at all okay but you're
talking about from the from the the chip
to the onboard memory that's generally
20 gigs a second for demo so if I have
three dims I can either chain them
together and basically use that in like
a three channel mode or whatever
something and get 60 each or in this
case I actually have three separate
memory controllers and each one is
getting the full 20 now how fast you
actually get comes down to the the
basically efficiency of your memory
access pattern right so for example in
in this case I've explicitly structured
the memory access so it doesn't write
it's not it's not the way we think of a
transpose right where it writes out all
thing in a big long chunk and then reads
strided where the stride is really large
because that's inefficient so I actually
have it right out in smaller pieces so
the next one is not as big of a stride I
can control that all manually I have
actual command kernels that send 64-bit
commands directly to my memory
controller and I can explicitly control
every part of the process how fast I
actually get comes down to how random
that access is how batched it is am i
opening up you know eight blocks at a
time and getting all the data out or am
i opening up a block here block there
milk if you want to continuously
transfer data how fast could you
continuously do it because again you had
the advantage of you're not batching or
caching or any of that kind of stuff so
if you can move it 20 gigs as long as
you have a 20 gig hole for it to go into
and a 20 gig source for it to come from
you're fine now you know if you have
some bottleneck somewhere else obviously
not gonna achieve that but but yeah you
could run at that full twenty it's the
same thing so for example this this will
do 200 cubes a second if I wanted to do
200 million cubes in a million seconds I
would just run it for a million times
longer you know it would but it wouldn't
at no point what I need to batch the
data because the data flows continuously
so I can I can theoretically process you
know hundreds of terabytes of data
because the amount of data I process is
just a matter of time it's not a matter
of actual storage for that hundreds of
terabytes of data other questions
[Music]
you will be going into incoming revenue
stream whatever you can I don't know I
don't know how many of those I really
can or should answer I mean I can give
you a little bit of the history that we
are we've been around for 13 years we
have generally been invested in by our
clients so that that sort of frees us
from we don't have massive amounts of
data or anything like that you know
basically people work with us and they
realize this is a technology that needs
investment and development and they
invest in us because they know it has a
future and for a lot of these people
that we're working with you know the
amount of money involved is not great
for them but it has the potential to
really you know produces sort of
longer-term benefits down the road so
they that's why they invest I'm not
really sure what more details I could
give you in a public setting I mean we
really do kind of look all across the
board we very rarely do just like a pure
hardware sale or a pure software sale
there's usually consulting services kind
of bundled with it
so a lot of our clients because they're
tiptoeing into the water on a new thing
right so it's not something where I can
just drop a box off at your door and let
you work with it so generally speaking
it's kind of a three-prong we sell the
hardware we sell the software we sell
the service of porting things into the
software what we're finding is that's
becoming less a part of the business
because we're now getting to a critical
mass where more people are wanting to do
it themselves we now have a lot of
clients there saying no teach us how to
do it give us the box but our
proprietary business logic we don't want
to give you we want to do that on our
own and own it and have the knowledge
developed in-house to maintain it that's
something that's happened more recently
so the business has always been kind of
a mix of hardware software and
consulting services really really all
three and it's very rare that we sell
one without the other two far cry from
the ordinary actuary I work with a lot
of really smart people it's best to make
me look good no I got into this because
'men working in finance I had started
GPUs that started to get very popular in
finance
it's becoming kind of a there's a lot of
sort of technically unsophisticated
people trying to do sophisticated things
that can get it can be frustrating so I
looked at it and I said I want to get on
the next technology that's not crowded
and that's right oh is this I said I
want to find a company that is using a
technology that nobody else is using in
a really experimental cutting-edge way
in finance and we do have a very
substantial finance business so that's
really how I got eaten to into the
organization but I've always been a kind
of amateur hacker in one way or another
and I've carried that in every
professional languages since the early
eighties I'm sort of curious for
instance if you guys have like used I up
one and I f2 is intermediate forms I'm
not yeah Livermore this little company
called digital equipment at one point in
time in Colorado State they heard that
need a disciple programming language
which was a very interesting language in
many respects but the problem was it
just it simply could not compete with
the mass of existing code
yeah and that's independent of this two
different lines of work done at MIT
before and one of whom I was trying to
get to come here because it's not
Carnegie Mellon or Carnegie photography
Belt independent the data flows so
there's all kinds of interesting things
that you know people did build data
flowing hardware and friends as mine
locally have run on data flow machines
and they ran into all kinds of
interesting questions that were not
really resolved I'm like you know
structures and all kinds of other stuff
like that like if you want to find
really one element of a same array as
example does that then invalidate the
whole array they have not thought about
that clients like sort of we've tried it
right but we've never actually gotten it
to produce a number that works and a lot
of times that's to convey that we bring
in is that you know because we've
just really gone do after doing this for
13 years and started knocking around all
the things that do and don't work
there's a lot of just really practical
knowledge built into the compiler so
that you know we make it to the point
where yes people can actually get
numbers at work out of simple code you
realize that one of the major benchmarks
was named simple and in fact it was my
understanding which is in the problem
spaces using up cycles that would
actually be interesting to compile it
into raw hardware and I think that would
be interesting on everything it's more a
matter of money right like that's it's
yeah you're talking about like building
an ASIC from it right there's nothing
about you know the hardware necessarily
I think it'd be interesting to that in
every case but most people are not
looking to spend tens of millions of
dollars to put out a chip and the
advantage really is is is you know the
way I always sell this to people is its
speed the speed of hardware not not as
good as an ASIC obviously because
nothing's gonna beat an ASIC but it's
very close in some ways the speed of
hardware at the design speed of software
and most people still need that design
speed they still need that ability to
especially like I should say a finance
client they introduce a new product or
there's a new twist on some derivative
and they need to change one little thing
in a model I can't do that if I already
have the gem right but I can do that
really easily if I'm doing everything in
software and the only real time
intensive part is the place in round you
know that which I if I have a good
simulator I shouldn't only be doing once
right I basically do that when I know
it's going to work and then it's more a
matter of just figuring out all the
issues in place and route like what
frequency and how to optimize the
resources and things like that yes I'm
kind of curious so my understanding is
everybody who's coming to you that's
something that they're already doing and
they now want to do you in your
experience of the people coming to you
been coming to you with mostly CPU code
or um we see a mix of both I mean
obviously my preferred starting point is
going to be CPU code because I'm not
going to keep most of it anyway right I
mean I'm gonna need to really understand
what it's doing to map it into a
different paradigm and I'd rather do
that without the overhead of figuring
out the just multi-core and the way the
parallelization works among the threads
and all that it's just easier to figure
it out but so for example there is a GPU
version of core espresso there's a CUDA
accelerated version and I haven't really
looked at it right because the way that
you would structure it's completely
different first of all you'd use a
library which I didn't use but you know
like I said you'd start by moving
everything into memory and working on it
in pieces and batches and it's a
completely different paradigm the way
we're doing it actually what's
interesting is the vast majority of my
code if you look at the code the FFT is
a tiny little part because I pulled that
out of a library we already had FFT
built I had FFT done all six of the FFT
is done the very first day it's one line
of code each very simple the tricky part
is the sphere in the circle that's the
tricky part right because you're moving
through that cube you hit the sphere and
you get entered at different points and
you come out of it at different points
and you have to keep all that in memory
[Music]
right and so for example with some of
these the GPU accelerated that's that's
a problem because GPUs like their memory
to be nice and rectangular right they
like it to be nice big blocks so yeah so
it for us
we think of it more as you know imagine
I've got a cube and I got a sphere in
the cube and I'm moving through it like
an ant crawling through it cell by cell
when do I pop in and out of the sphere
and I have to know all of the different
dimensions of all the different points
of the sphere to be able to do that
that's really where all of the real work
was and none of that has any analog in
CPU or GPU or anything else
and I'm starting with code it's easier
for me to look at code that's really
basic and says this does an FFT and
start from that but yeah we have clients
that come to us generally speaking I
mean they're more likely to come with
CPU code because they're more likely
than to need performance right they're
more likely to have a problem that
whereas you know if they've invested the
money in a GPU project okay maybe I
don't have the performance I want but I
put a lot of money in it it's already
better and maybe I don't want to do any
better than that
but it's easier if you're starting from
far behind it's also easier if you come
in with few assumptions the best things
are the clients that come in and say I
know what I want in a quant qualitative
sense right I need a picture that makes
sense so for our seismic modeling people
for example I need a picture of the oil
field that physically makes sense right
I don't need 64-bit precision I don't
actually need to know that that'll that
read is read you know 100 point oh woah
oh 1 instead of 100 point oh oh - you
know it's red right it's it's I'm going
to make a quantitative qualitative
decision those are the best coins right
because those are people we can come in
and say let's open up your algorithm
open up your thinking talk about
precision talk about maximizing your
qualitative result for the minimum
amount of compute time and energy in
space so so what's nice about anybody
else we actually partnered with them on
that we had sort of they've been talking
to us long before that was announced so
AWS has released an f1 instance I think
right now it's only available in the US
region I'm not sure that that instance
is the same chip as what we were using
it is not exactly the same the whole
board because Amazon likes to do things
like protect their PCIe pins you don't
want you don't want to give someone raw
access to PCIe pins in a data center
that's a really bad idea but the idea is
the same so we're not quite there yet
but it should be happening in the next
month or two where we'll have now a
version of the compiler that would
compile for f1 so you'll take that data
flow it's the same max J it's just
you'll flip a switch here and there to
say I'm compiling for a different
architecture I believe Amazon's
as you send them the VHDL and they build
the the FPGA image off it but we will
have the the ability to run pretty much
anything that's run on the latest
generation of hardware should be pretty
easily portable into AWS and that's
coming probably in the next month or so
if you're a student or if you're not a
student we usually go to dinner
afterwards and I'm hungry so as am I
you